joining me right here on the rich eisen
show from the worldwide leader in sports
and he will be
a part of their draft coverage the in an
integral part
of their draft coverage for all three
days two nights one day starting next
week in cleveland ohio
also uh one of the expert analysts on
monday night football lewis riddick back
here on the show how are you sir
rich eisen how are you man thanks for
having me back better for talking to you
better for talking to you all right
louis uh let's get into it i've asked
this question of many
um so uh i appreciate your insights that
you will be adding to this
is it your belief is it possible that
the niners
made this maneuver from 12 to three
using all the draft capital that they
used to go get it
to choose a position
that will only serve as an evaluation
all the way through to the draft or did
they
know they were going to go get at number
three assuming that wilson and lawrence
would be off the board
your thoughts yeah i think
they had an idea of who they wanted
i think they obviously rich i think
all personnel departments will leave
themselves open to changing their mind
simply because you can always get
information later on in the process that
can possibly sway you especially if you
have some guys who are very
closely grouped which when we're talking
about quarterbacks and we're talking
about these specific quarterbacks
there's no way you can definitively say
that between trey lance justin fields
and mack jones that
one is just head and shoulders above the
other
in terms of being a productive
high level performer in the envelope
there's no way you can say that
you could subjectively argue one guy for
another based on what your tastes are
and what
i don't know whatever you perceive to be
you know something that you see
that somebody else doesn't see but all
things being equal there's no way you
can say that one guy is going to be so
much better than the other
and i think with san francisco i think
even they even if they have an idea of
who they wanted
even if they had an idea of who they
were going up to get
i think they're going to leave
themselves some wiggle room and say hey
look if somewhere here late in this
process somebody just blows our doors
off and we
we wind up getting a level of comfort
with them that we didn't have previously
then we can change our mind
and look i always tell this story that
kind of thing it isn't always that you
know you have to
know because everyone thinks that you
have to know what you
you know what you want to do because if
you don't i've heard people say well
it's just irresponsible
no it's not it's not irresponsible for
them to do this
they can do whatever the hell they want
because in the end if the guy winds up
being the right guy and maybe it was
someone who
you know they didn't initially think
that they that they uh had favored
and then they wind up winning the super
bowl are we going to hold it against
kyle
and john and say well that isn't who
adam schefter said you were going to be
you know what we're not going to
celebrate that you know you or you pay
too much for that guy so guess what this
skill doesn't it can't
no one cares in the end you just care
about getting it right we did that in
2004 rich when i was in washington
we went in the night before the draft
saying we were going to draft keller
winslow junior
coming winter second whatever the night
before the draft
we had a big meeting the night before
the entire personnel department entire
uh
coaching staff and we were arguing like
kids in there
about who would be the better pro and
there was them near 50 50.
the next morning we come back and we
flipped it sean taylor first kellen
winslow second we draft sean taylor he's
on his way to a hall of fame career
before he's taken away from us and it
was the smartest move we could have made
so look i don't need for them to have
to have it set in stone who they want to
pick they need to have it set in stone
when they're on the clock
that's what matters well it is amazing
louis how
how it all works out and i had a front
row seat for it with mayok
for all those years okay mike's on nfl
network and his word
to so many fans gospel absolute
gospel and then in his first draft he
chooses cleland farrell
with the first chance he's got to draft
someone for the raiders
and so few people were talking about him
and everyone's like mark doesn't know
what the hell he's doing
whereas if mike was on nfl network
pounding the table for farrell
all along and somebody else for the
raiders drafting chose someone other
than farrell
fans would have been like why the hell
did you choose the guy that mayok wanted
you know and mayok's the one who's now
actually making the pick
yeah and folks are like well wait a
minute i've heard this name for
three straight weeks i didn't hear that
name this person doesn't know what
they're doing
so the concept is it was mac jones now
it's justin fields
and i asked this of ian rap report
what's changed or
it's just our viewpoint of it right so
what do you think would be the best
choice for the niners
three overall lewis yeah you know what
nancy
that question there's a
i can't how do i put this
i can't necessarily say what's best
simply because of this
there's information that they have that
none of us
well most of us don't have like you know
we all have phones right we all pick up
and talk to people right yes
they know things as far as
intelligence tests as far as
psychological evaluations as far as
medical evaluation which is the most
important thing about all this
right they factor into this decision and
then it becomes a subjective thing
which even you know that right so uh
kyle can be sitting here going look i
value this this and this in a player
more so
than this this and this i may value
decision making and accuracy
more so than i value uh you know
athletic ability and arm talent i value
the way i feel around this player as far
as how i think i can get along with this
player
over the other so there's so many
different things that really go into
determining
who is the best person more so than just
watching tape so all right on on it's on
the surface
look i think trey lance of those three
has the potential both in terms of
makeup intelligence athletic ability
height weight speed running ability all
the different things that he can do
and i've talked to this young man and
looked him in the eye and talked to him
in person
he's the guy who i really like out of
this entire group
i love mac jones too because i know how
smart quarterbacks
win smart quarterbacks who have
competent levels of talent
they win in the nfl because i also know
that dumb football loses in the nfl
people forget that right now right now
we don't want to talk about that we just
want to talk about height weight and
speed
dumb football loses in the nfl it just
does every time
and you and the statistics bear it out
he's the guy who coaches love because he
doesn't play dumb football
he can almost match you move for move
on the field like a coach meaning
matching defensive coordinators and
defensive coordinators hate guys like
that
they hate guys like that who are almost
on par with them from a strategic
standpoint and mac gives you that
then and you know what trey lands when
you talk to people about him
he is getting to that level too and he
has the ability to do that as well as
anyone
justin same thing if you talk to ryan
day justin fields is a very intelligent
quarterback very
intelligent that is still on his way up
and may have the most physical upside of
them all
so who is the best guy
for me knowing what i know when you
marry
the physical with the mental
and everything that comes with it in the
package from the limited exposure i've
had to these young men
i am a big fan of treylan
how about that a big fan big big fan
but they haven't they have other
information that i know
that i don't and none of not none of the
other people who are talking about these
quarterbacks don't
so just be prepared as you know you've
done this a long time when you're
sitting in that seat
next thursday night be prepared for
anything because anything can happen and
it probably will
and then there's this sense also too
though and then i just want to bounce
this off you and then move on
uh lewis redick of espn bucky brooks my
colleague from the nfl media group
pointed out that you know when the trade
hit
for the niners and and the dolphins it
was during zach wilson's pro day
so obviously it had to be done leading
up to
zach wilson's prote so thus the
quarterbacks that were
potentially being traded up for the
niners to get
um and that they would have been happy
with if you will
included zach wilson as they were making
this trade
so if you know there's no magic number
we've been saying the three quarterbacks
that the niners were willing to go get
and trade up to and while they would do
this evaluation to make sure as you
pointed out earlier in this conversation
that
the tape grinding would come to a
consensus eventually and has to anyway
yeah
that that zack wilson was in that mix
and maybe mac jones never was
that's what he threw out there too that
that
that the the quarterbacks that the
niners were looking at were really
zach wilson trey lance and justin fields
because they're all of a similar if you
will physical height weight speed skill
set and mac jones just not what do you
make of that
what do you think of that i mean you
know what i'll i'll just default to this
adam scepter who we know
is sometimes you think adam's actually
sitting in some of these meetings
okay i mean it's like god how do you
know that that's because his phone is
plugged into the back of his head like
the matrix lewis
he's okay he wouldn't
say what he has already said about
who about maybe who some of the
some of the quarterbacks are that the
49ers like if he didn't know that
definitively
he doesn't throw stuff out there for the
heck of it so for him to say
that the 49ers like matt jones
as he has gone on record is saying it is
not because
he matt jones was never in the
conversation
matt jones has been in the conversation
i've been told mac jones has been in the
conversation
so this is not one of those where
actually oh they're just kind of running
a smoke screen and they
kind of leaking out there that he is but
he's not no he is
he he's definitely in it for sure
as far as zach wilson is concerned
i'll say this steve young has said and
you know steve you know
obviously steve dialed into byu yep
these dialed into
the 49ers steve has said well you know
49ers would love to get their hands on
zach
so there's no question that they would
love to who knows maybe the jets
for some reason or another which i can't
foresee
don't pick zach oh please wouldn't that
make it a pretty fun night next thursday
no it would not louis and
no it would not and the host sitting
next to you would agree
that host sitting here you know what no
that that's true too he probably passed
out
you get somebody else to go i might have
to slide over in that chair and then all
hell
please i think reese davis would have to
host all three shows at that time
he better be ready but you know what
i think i think there's no question that
they would like to have him too maybe
most of these quarterback coaches what i
mean
that's a phenomenal talent man i mean
this is what's so
like i mean we've said this so i've said
this so many times
like quarterback evaluation like we're
so
predetermined right now to believe that
quarterbacks have to look a certain way
from an athletic and aesthetic
standpoint
in order to win but man i mean just
let's go back
10 15 let's just go back from this year
and this could work backwards 10 to 15
years
and when we when we start playing the
games and you start hosting
shows on sunday mornings and talking
about games
what is the keys that we always kind of
resort back to
revert back to as far as how a team is
going to win or not lose
what do we talk about situational
football turnovers not throwing
interceptions making smart decisions
we don't say well this guy has to make
this off-schedule 50-yard throw sidearm
you know body parallel like pat
patrick mahomes in the super bowl we
don't talk about that right
and yet at this time of year we're just
like drunk with the with the height
weight and speed measurable i mean this
absolutely intoxicated
on our behind talking about it and we
know that when we get back to the 11 on
11
there's a certain thing that nfl over
time have always determined the outcome
of games and always will
and that's why we just and we and we
just forget about it at this time of
year and i think we have to remember
that the
coaches value certain things
at a much higher level at all times of
the year
not just when the games are starting and
right now is one of those times of year
where they're sitting in meetings and
they're talking about this kind of thing
and that's why a guy like mack jones for
as much as people may
hate the way he plays the game relative
to the superstars
in this league he is in the mix man
okay he is in the mix and he's gonna
play a long time in the nfl
a couple more minutes left with louis
riddick here uh on the rich eisen show
espn analyst as well as nfl
uh you know nfl live analyst and he'll
be on the the draft set
on thursday night and throughout for
espn and also in the monday night
football booth the hyphenate
uh here on the rich eisen show you said
that we're all drunk on height weight
speed this time of the year so we must
be doing bed spins over kyle pitts
together
no doubt so walk me through the the the
falcons
draft room and meetings with arthur
blank right now best you can
take a guess what a tough situation
they're in at four
okay it sounds like a good situation but
it's a tough situation so you're trying
to balance a short term with the long
term
take care of this team right now how do
we help this team win immediately
because fans want to see wins otherwise
they don't come to the stadium
versus how do we plan for four or five
years down the road especially at
quarterback in the event that matt ryan
hits some kind of wall that everyone
hits
supposedly except for tom brady and we
have to have a plan of succession
so this trey lance dustin fields are
they in the conversation
here did we just pick the best player
available and take kyle pitts which is
you know i think you know pretty much a
consensus opinion
or do we try and trade out of this spot
how far do we go
to where the map the value matches up
for us as far as maybe getting something
that really helps this team which is
defense in particular
whatever level it is whether it's pass
rusher second level linebacker or
corner cover guy impact player in the
secondary those are the three scenarios
that they're probably trying to pass
through right now
and it's a tough decision it really is
because
again you're trying to balance what
helped us win games right now
what else what helps us in the future as
far as building a sustainable
championship level organization
and terry i'm sure terry fought noted gm
and uh and arthur smith and mr blank are
all trying to kind of figure that out
because
you know if they if they can't get a
good trade partner to move back with
i think they're just going to turn in
the car and take kyle pitts and then
continue to address this defense
throughout the rest of the draft and as
free agency continues to play itself out
all the way up until the season i think
so right because they're not a player to
away
but they're going to have to pick
someone if they don't get a trade
partner and i think best player
available at that point it's probably
going to be kyle pitts so
you roll with it don't i think i mean i
you you put him out there on the field
you got two more maybe two years left i
mean we had thomas dimitrov on
talking about how the contract was
redone with the sense of
as it was initially done to keep matt
ryan uh
in the falcons uniform for his entire
career um
he might think about maybe playing past
this contract but that's for
a can to be kicked down the road for
another time pitts is going to be there
for the next quarterback along with
ridley
right i mean why not
right yeah no no it makes sense it makes
sense but you know
really i mean i mean kyle kyle's going
to be fantastic provided everything
works out for him and
he stays healthy you know he's he's look
he's an x factor we all know that
right but they have to
they have to make sure that whatever
personal acquisition vehicle that they
use they better make sure they get some
firepower on defense or
which they're not going anywhere that's
true they're not going anywhere i don't
care how pretty it looks on the
perimeter for them they're not going
anywhere
they just aren't you you can't you can't
keep you can't survive the way that team
is presently constructed which is so
offensive heavy
it's so everything's about offense
scoring points and it's all about
perimeter
that's where all their production is
coming quarterback wide receivers
the pretty glitz and glamour position
the meat of that team
is weak often the line isn't as strong
as it needs to be they can't rush the
passer to save their soul they've thrown
so much money at it
now they've got they've had some better
pressures and better pressure percentage
last year in particular they need to put
quarterbacks on the ground
they need to get off the field on third
down they need to play
a high efficiency level and a higher
level of defense in terms of efficiency
right and they just don't
and they've got to get some better
players so unless they do that
and kyle pitts is nice and that's an
easy pick
but what else are they going to do to
build that team and that's really what
their problem is going to be going
forward
lewis thanks for the time uh when i see
you in cleveland know in advance i'm
double vaxxed
um and uh i look forward to it and then
brother dave and look for my call after
the draft too i'd love to have you back
on i'll let you
to get your two cents on it i really
really truly enjoy your perspective and
i look forward to seeing you soon
absolutely my man i'll see you up there
right back at you that's louis riddick
must follow on twitter at l riddick espn
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here